hi there steve coffin here
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
here i talk about language learning of
course
and i have been asked by the way to do
videos in russian and in japanese and
maybe or sometimes in portuguese and i
always say i will and then i end up not
doing it because the problem is that
not everyone understands those languages
then may get requests for subtitles
um
but if there's people want me to speak
in different languages i will
what do you want me to speak about in
which languages so i have requests for
russian japanese i think portuguese if
there are others let me know and i will
try to schedule them
now today i would like to talk about
something that sort of crossed my mind i
always think about language learning
because i have to admit it's a major
part of my
life i enjoy learning them i enjoy using
them i enjoy it when i meet people that
i can speak to in languages that i have
learned i enjoy going to the countries
where i can
you know communicate
right now with my arabic like this
morning i was reading in al jazeera
looking up every you know 50 60 of the
words it doesn't matter i was getting a
different perspective
on events in in the middle east and
through uh you know arabic
uh gradually i will learn those words
not overnight obviously
so i enjoy it and so i think about the
relationship between other things
and language learning
and one thing that struck me is
that like right now in my arabic i feel
that i'm starting to turn a corner i
have put so much
time and effort into listening and
reading and reviewing my words and
and of course all of this stuff
gradually gradually accumulates you're
not conscious you have the feeling that
you're learning and forgetting and
learning and forgetting but all the
while when you're learning and
forgetting and listening and so forth
this is like sediment that's collecting
in your brain
and and it's building up
to a point where suddenly
things become clearer
things start to stick better
and so it says
gradual imperceptible
process
i've said before that
as in many things we tend to
overestimate or we expect
very rapid you know progress and
evidence progress
uh but then we don't realize the longer
term we underestimate the extent to
which we are learning in the long term
and that reminds me of something that
was said by a
lady that i knew was very much into
gardening
and there is apparently an expression
when it comes to gardens
the first year it sleeps
the second year it creeps
and the third year it leaps
so the garden if you put in a new garden
the first year there's nothing there you
just planted some small
shrubs or
bulbs for flowers or small little
seedlings or whatever it is you planted
in the second year it grows a little so
it creeps but in the third year it leaps
it jumps
and that's what happens with language
learning we're unaware of the extent to
which we are
putting things into our brain
that are starting to connect that are
creating the conditions
so that later on all of a sudden our
language learning can start or our
ability and our comprehension can start
to creep and then
leap all right
and
perhaps to continue on that theme the
key thing that we have to sock into
place
uh is comprehension in my view
and i had an interesting exchange on
twitter with various language teachers
who were
again sort of lamenting the fact that
very often
either
certainly adult learners
want to speak now or
the younger learners don't care
as one teacher said he's never been
asked by his young students
i want to speak i want to write
so the younger learners will quite
happily focus on comprehension and
vocabulary and so forth but the older
the adults seem to want i want to speak
now and of course the whole
instructional system is based on getting
people to say things now and to say it
accurately and of course in my view
that's
you can speak early it's good it it it
stimulates you it even helps in
developing comprehension but it needn't
be accurate it needs to be correct you
didn't have to worry about grammar or
anything else you want to get that
comprehension in
comprehension is kind of like the
fertilizer there's all these leaves that
are falling in there that are
decomposing and becoming fertilizer so
that at a later stage your garden can
leap and you can leap forward and of
course as i always say eventually you
have to do a lot of speaking but it has
to be based on this firm this rich soil
of comprehension of words and so forth
so in language learning
the first year
it sleeps
like a garden the second year it creeps
and the third year it leaps now that
needn't be three years it can be six
months six months six months or three
months three months three months
depending on
how different the language is from
languages you already speak
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you